this is the meme it says when you are
looking for the basic difference between
the left and the right look to the young
our 17 year old versus their 17 year old
and this meme is shared by the left and
the right in the exact same way to make
the exact same point I just want to make
an argument real quick about the
simulation if you if you guys remember
they have the same birthday too yeah was
it January 17th birthday and Greta have
the same birthday so we are we talked
about that I think with him with
writtenhouse that's right Luke
encouraged him to get married this is
crazy Joe crazy well she's she's a
foreign leftist climate change Global
Elite and he is a working class Suburban
slash rural American kid but you're an
active insane the other dimension they
flip it off and see her as the working
class right no no well I think they do I
think they see her as like this more
blue-collar like activist and they see
him as like this privileged elitist
honestly I actually I I think I think
one of them obviously stands for Liberty
and they are are incredibly opposed to
that everything that that that that
image stands for they're incredibly
opposed to when it comes to like the
liberal Elite and control and and you
know passing more government regulation
when it comes to climate change and
everything like that that agenda is the
most attractive thing to them because
that agenda to them is safety it's that
like uh government-controlled safe world
that you live in whereas the other one's
a little bit more risky but there's more
Liberty I can sense as their keep
advancing carbon capture technology now
like oil companies are withdrawing the
carbon from the air and storing it
underground they're learning how to turn
it into graphene for building it's the
the the the the momentum of the climate
change thing is fizzling you I can sense
it on the internet like it's just not
exciting to complain about the future of
carbon when people know you can easily
more at least actively pull it out like
it's becoming obvious that the next
problem is going to be taking too much
carbon out of the air that's really
interesting that you're saying that I'm
not even familiar with that uh but but
technology every single year it's like
just open New York better and better
they were concerned about horse crap on
the streets of New York and the car got
invented so did you guys know about do
you guys know about 15-minute cities
sort of I've heard this idea that in the
future everybody will live within 15
minutes of whatever they need you'll
never need to really go anywhere you'll
have whatever you want there's this
really funny video I just saw someone
send it to me and it's a guy explaining
15-minute cities and he says I want to
explain to you the concept of the
15-minute City and then he walks up to
the shed thing and opens it and there's
chickens standing there and he goes
these are its citizens inside their
15-minute City they have everything they
could ever need then they walk inside
and goes there is food and water readily
available now they can leave whenever
they want they don't want to because
it's scary and it's dangerous outside
and why inside here they own nothing but
they're happy and he said and then he
walks into the room and he's like this
is where they produce things that I can
take for free and then he picks the eggs
up and he puts them in his sweater and
he's like here's a couple here's a
couple and he's like see in the
15-minute City you will owe nothing you
will be happy you'll be provided for and
then we can take everything from you
it really is a great video explaining
what their plan is how the how these
city planners how these how the Davos
group types want to run the show
treating us like chickens making us do
the work that they can take and keeping
you locked in a chicken coop I want you
living and dying on an assembly line you
know that's it do you think as you guys
were saying that I was like well they
don't want him doing that they want like
a thinking class of people to join them
basically like do you guys think about
the plebs and the elites like do you
think there's a class differential the
Romans would say that's the plebs was it
like a nutrition issue like all these
people they're from people that didn't
have nutrition for Generations they've
been bred to be stupid workers and then
the Elite Class have all the good food
they can think they can write the law
yeah it's the the what is the morlocks
and the which ones that I don't know was
it warlocks yeah I know what you're
talking about yeah time machine or
something
uh
I'm looking at morlocks uh fictional
species
in the antagonists or the morlocks in
the he goes to the Future where humans
have evolved into two different species
one's really dumb and one's really smart
this is from The Time Machine yeah oh
Loi Loi that's what it is Loi or
something yeah take a look at this
article in the daily mail if there's a
civil war I'm fighting Trump loyalists
face off with staunch liberals outside
former presidents NYC tower on the eve
of his room at arrest I saw this article
and I thought it was really funny
considering the context because like I
appreciate the protesters right but I
was thinking about it and like I see
this picture of this dude I don't know
who he is uh Diane cine 54 founder of
trumpswag.com eating that cheeseburger
in the french fries and I'm like
look he doesn't look like he's out of
shape or anything I'm just like think
about what this Civil War is going to
look like it's not gonna so in like the
Confederates had just I don't know if
you guys have ever seen a true
Confederate uniform very basic Union
uniforms were like blue or whatever it
was all very basic mass-produced stuff
but like a modern Civil War is going to
be weird as hell there's gonna be people
wearing like Uniqlo turtlenecks and
antifa it'll be like Walmart versus
forever 21. those are the outfits well I
mean worse than that it's gonna be like
hunger City like Hunger Games Capital
City people with like you know half
their head is shaved and the hair is
spiked to the side and they've got weird
body modifications and they're going to
be waving gigantic multi-colored flags
of all different kinds you can't discern
who is on what side because all the
flags are different but all you know is
that their flag doesn't have Trump on it
they're probably not on your side then
you're gonna have people waving Trump
flags of all different types and it's
like it's gonna get crazy yeah it'll be
that they them Army against uh probably
probably a pretty that'd be they'd be
pretty heavily armed I would imagine the
right wing would be you know yeah a lot
of people bring up like the military
getting involved and whatnot I would
imagine if it were to actually go down
it's not like military versus you it's
military splits as well same as the
nation military leaders that are more
right-leaning and you know believe in
whatever they would believe in and
people die with that side man I think
people really need to start reading
about the Civil War because I am by no
means an expert in any way but even just
visiting Gettysburg I'm like oh I guess
so much I did not know like for instance
I learned when I went to Gettysburg that
one of the reasons the Confederates lost
was because they were using muzzle
loaded rifles but they unioned It
upgraded to breach loading rifles that
means the union would breach loading is
you you crack the gun kind of breaks in
half on a hinge like a shotgun you know
you ever see like Elmer fudge load a
shotgun breach load you break it open
you put the shell in you close it you
can fire
the Confederates were trying to muzzle
load and the Union soldiers were just
firing
boom real quickly that was a
technological advantage a lot of people
don't know that they don't know what
happened or why most people don't know
the Confederates could have won the war
in the first fight I think the First
Battle of Bull Run they could have just
walked into DC and and won instantly and
they decided not to there's so much so
much but the important thing is the
reason I bring it up how I think it was
like was it Lee who was talking they're
all they're all West Point guys and then
they were like but I can't fight against
my own State I have no choice but to
leave and go back home right people
don't get that that you're gonna have
somebody who's gonna be like I grew up
here you are not gonna send me to occupy
my own Street Corner somebody who was
born and raised in West Virginia who's
like now living in DC because it's only
about an hour two hour drive depending
on where you're at I mean if you're in
Central West Virginia it could be four
or five hours but then they're like okay
now we're gonna have you go with this
gun to to you know your state and
they're gonna be like I don't know if I
can do that right yeah that will happen
Shelby Foote is a historian someone I
was looking at a lot reading when I was
writing in this book and he said he's
from the south he said something about
the union thought they were fighting to
keep the union together and the South
was fighting the second American
Revolution but there were a lot of
people who lived down there who didn't
give a crap about the war at all but if
you came into their territory they're
going to fight you which to the union
looks like you're a Confederate but
they're just defending their property
exactly as an invading Force exactly
yeah and in the South they were like
there would be sons who saw the north as
an invading force and their fathers
fought the British and the revolution
who saw the British as innovating Force
yeah so it's like two generations in a
row basically of fighting invading
forces that's crazy super crazy wow it's
wild I mean I haven't even checked out
any of that stuff like I haven't gone to
any of those Battlegrounds
Gettysburg is cool cool place I mean the
whole city is basically a civil war
yeah we we ride our bikes past Antietam
like whenever we whenever we're going up
uh we go up to uh what's that little
town uh do you know which one it is
Hagerstown no no there's a little little
bitty one Sharpsburg Sharpsburg yeah the
best ice cream in America I know man for
those who don't know there's like this
really Fame it's like a dollar for this
bowl of ice crazy yeah but I mean right
there and it's it's beautiful and they
have they they they've put up all of
these Civil War informational things
everywhere you go we're really close to
John Brown's uh raid headquarters in
Harpers Ferry John Brown's house is the
only place I ever felt a black lives
matter flag should be I was like okay
that that makes sense there the one in
Ohio for John Brown no in Harpers Ferry
I agree because I think they would but
like you would like it John Brown I
think was a crazy was a crazy person
well I think he had something right
about slavery being bad
yeah about it the wrong way but that's
the problem I had with antifa two right
like antifa is like hey there's a bad
thing happening in government like yeah
I really agree about that so why did you
fire bomb a black person's business
right and you know it's like well like
dude John Brown raids an Armory and none
of the slaves wanted to fight with him
they were like dude what are you doing
with all his sons yeah yeah and it's
just not to mention he just went
murdered people and then there's
Bleeding Kansas and all that stuff A lot
of people are like dude we agree with
you but
this is not the way we go we want to go
about doing it I don't know I don't
think he was right but there's a
question of whether or not the the
people who are refusing to fight were
writers believe he thought slavery was
just going against God and he was had a
calling by God I believe he was trying
to do it right but he wasn't right about
going violating people in the face the
violence part is where I stopped too is
I don't obviously don't want violence
yeah I think of that I think the first
person hanged by the federal government
is that true I I think no he was one of
the Virginia I'm pretty sure I think he
was one of the first people I forget
where it was I have to look that up one
of the first people of something yeah
I'm enjoying all those things we did a
video the other day asking people if um
the Civil War was enough payment for
like slavery reparations and stuff like
if that was enough payment in terms of
what like in terms of like there's talk
about just a bunch of cash but yeah yeah
the Bloodshed and stuff seeing like hey
was that a sufficient payment for
slavery or no I love when white people
are saying that uh this they did nothing
white people did nothing for slavery I'm
like well white people also did fight
the Civil War and won it you should know
and stopped it right not only did
hundreds of thousands of lines like two
million
horrible yeah
uh in this book that are based on like
diary entries from different soldiers
from all over the place and some from
both sides that you could smell the
blood in their diet like in terms of how
they write it between six between 600
and 1 million dead yeah and so on the
union side you had 290 000 dead Union
Soldiers
the Confederate side was 365 000 dead
soldiers the total casualties endured
prison of Wars Etc 864 000 on the union
side and 828 000 on the Confederate side
so it's like 290
000 people died 864 000 people suffered
some kind of injury is that not enough
for the country to be ripped apart
for people to be shooting and killing
each other for the the march to the sea
the ransacking and destruction of the
burning of Richmond none of that when
they come out and they're like this
country was both on slavery it's like
and it's also burned down partly because
of it so I mean I kind of feel like you
know the payment's done you know when
slavery was abolished there was the
population was like 25 million people so
I you know they're they're it's
obviously it's evil what was happening
with slavery but to to suggest that uh
the country was built on slavery it's
like really the slaves built in New York
or like what are you talking about I
mean to be fair like in a certain
respect yes in a lot of these places
slaves did construction slaves worked at
the stores and a lot of people don't
understand this either most most I would
imagine if you ask one you should maybe
do this most Americans view of a slave
is probably coming from these movies
where it's like a a black man in the
field being whipped what they don't also
realize is that a lot of slaves were
like cobblers and there were people
there were people in cities working at
stores and do doing regular trade work
but they just weren't getting they
weren't free to leave they couldn't do
whatever they wanted they couldn't own
property they couldn't read or write or
or some of them could but they typically
couldn't people understand that slaves
did all manners of work and like none of
it was good you keep taking away
someone's agency to strip them from from
the work they produce is like the
antithesis of what this country is
supposed to be but in that respect yeah
in places like New York slaves did
provide a large component and then the
country ripped in half
shouted each other like crazy cities
were burnt to the ground
nearly 2 million people suffered some
kind of casualty with nearly a million
dead and I'm kind of like what is that
125th of the entire population suffered
uh died what was let me let me let no
that that's right that's right yeah I
think 25 million would probably be a
high uh estimate during the the Civil
War is that adult age or uh total I
think that's total I believe that's
still at the top of my head 25 million
uh 31 million people
there were third in 1860 the US
population was 31 million I wonder how
many adults so one thirtieth of the
country died
because of yeah mostly because of
slavery I mean you ask people who are
from the south and who have family in
history they'll tell you it wasn't
because of slavery and
people need to understand the Nuance
there it's like you were saying for
somebody who just lived in you know I
don't know Arkansas or something you've
got Union Soldiers marching through
shooting burning and you're like I don't
know or care you know you're fighting
right the other thing is
people will will look at the Civil War
and be like the Union's all good
Confederates all bad I mean if you know
anything about history it's just that's
such a false word looking at it pretty
sure the most evil dude in the whole
thing was Sherman Sherman hated black
people uh I wrote about it fairly
extensively and then also was okay with
one of his one of his guys who was I
believe a general uh someone beneath him
though so you're not a general but he
was a union guy who happened to be named
Jefferson Davis
oddly enough so the simulation's been
happening since the Civil War but this
this Union soldier named Jefferson Davis
was in charge of they didn't they didn't
like freed slaves following them so they
killed them they pulled out the bridge
from beneath them as they were trying to
cross a river in Georgia during the
march of the sea killed them I believe
it was hundreds I put it in the book
it's a crazy thing real quick for them
for people who don't know the march to
the sea I believe was the first instance
of scorched Earth scorched Earth here
yeah yeah dude scorched Earth refers to
in war destroying arable land burning
down houses killing civilians Etc so
that nothing can be rebuilt and you
decimate their their chances they would
reconstruct they would make Sherman
neckties they'd burn the railroad tracks
and and then pull them and stretch them
around trees so the trains couldn't get
to the Confederate camps uh burned
everything down and there's a lot of
people who would claim that Sherman came
to their house and burnt it down but
they're also people who were like uh
advantageous and become Marauders and
had nothing to do with Sherman but then
went and destroyed things to pilfer
because that's still his fault exactly
yeah because he created the atmosphere
where where it's actual hell on Earth he
said he wanted to make the South uh I
believe squeal scorched
I put this in the book I look at Sherman
as our first atom bomb you know and yeah
he went down to the South and just
decimated and those people are reeling
from that to the today like in the town
in the book you know even though Sherman
didn't make it to this exact Town these
people have family dating back to the
revolution in Georgia pre-georgia pre
United States and they're still feeling
like effects from just how decimated
Georgia was from the sea so for the
people who are in the south
because there was a percentage of these
states who were in favor of staying with
the union and who opposed slavery in
fact Virginia initially voted to stay
with the union and it wasn't until the
federal troops got sent down to Fort
Sumter that they just or I think it was
slightly after this they were like whoa
this is getting crazy we're going to
break off and then four more states
joined so for what people don't realize
is that these states weren't in unison
being like hurray a secession there was
a vote and there was a split and there
was debate yeah so let's say you're a
family that just happened to live in
Georgia let's put it this way let's put
it in a modern context let's say you are
living in Shepherdstown West Virginia
it's like fairly woke huh oh yeah but
you're in West Virginia which is 86
percent Mago imagine if there was a
Civil War and West Virginia being modern
country gets gets invaded by Union
soldiers and then the the union let's
say Federal National Guard come in take
over your house occupy it you have no
idea why even though you're like I don't
agree with these people I don't like
what's going on they just there's
gunfights and they burn down your
property and everything you're family
owned is now gone do you deserve
reparations
after the war is done immediately after
should they come and say we're sorry
that our invasion of the state had a
negative impact on you we are going to
help rebuild your home actually at the
uh that's there's actually I believe
like a statute for that um because it's
like during some current uh it has to
follow around like a current time so you
would deserve reparations
immediately after if the federal
government did something like that and I
will say real quick about the massacre
about uh with what I was saying with
Sherman and March to see Lincoln did go
down and then he took some land from
people and gave it to the families of
the free slaves that who did survive
well so yeah here's my point let's say
you were a family in Georgia and you're
like we don't we don't like slavery we
don't be involved in slavery we don't
want to secede from the union we can't
control it we're not in politics we're
just some farmers who mind our own
business then Sherman comes walks up to
your house and throws a torch in it
destroys everything you your kids
struggle to survive maybe some siblings
die now it's a hundred or so years later
and you're living in a trailer where
your family used to be you know farmers
of of modest living and moderate living
you are now impoverished do you deserve
reparations for the destruction the
Union forces brought to your land if
it's 100 years later I have a hard time
saying yes to that I'm not saying yes or
no I'm saying when they go to
Californians and say we're gonna give
you operations despite the fact that
California was admitted as a free state
and has always been against it it's like
it's just absolutely ridiculous yeah
it's a virtue well what they're talking
about in California is San Francisco
they're talking about five million
dollars per uh descendant of slave or
whatever you have to check a couple
boxes there's like eight options and if
you check like a few of them or whatever
you can get five million dollars and
it's like an unbelievable amount of
money but also California as a whole
July they have 223 000 that they're
trying to give to
um each Senator slave in the state you
don't need to be black you need to
identify as black it did say that that's
true and so we went over this and
there's there's certain criteria where
someone like Rachel dolezal will be
eligible thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time